es una oración para que el alma de
cristel descanse en paz cinco meses
después de su muerte su madre magny aún
está de duelo una vez a la semana viene
con sus dos nietos a este terreno vacío
que sirve como cementerio para velar la
tumba de su hija asesinada en octubre de
crystal tenía 24 años fue apuñalada por
su ex novio en este barrio de duala sus
dos hijos pequeños fueron testigos de la
constante violencia que padecía su madre
mi padre le pegó la echó de la casa
y dormimos bajo la lluvia con tan solo
cuatro y ocho años los niños observaron
impotentes el asesinato de su madre ya
mi madre volvió del mercado cuando entró
yo quise cerrar la puerta vi que ella
estaba alterada vi que era el centro y
durante un minuto solo se quedó ahí mi
madre le dijo que había dicho que no
volvieras aquí él se molestó sacó un
cuchillo y la apuñaló con el asesino de
cristal está en la cárcel pero su madre
todavía carga con la profunda sensación
de injusticia la muerte de su hija la ha
sumido en el duelo y en la dificultad
económica
christel era proveedora de la familia
ahora magny que está desempleada depende
de la generosidad de sus vecinos
desde que murió mi hija se acabó toda mi
vida ella era mi mano derecha lo era
todo para mí
hacía todo por
cristal se ha ido y si nadie me ayuda me
quedaré en la calle los niños las
personas que viven aquí a veces me dan
mil con mil francos para que pueda
cocinar estoy desesperada estoy
sufriendo esto no está bien
la comisión nacional de derechos humanos
en camerún afirma que al menos 130
mujeres fueron asesinadas por sus
parejas entre 2019 y 2020 pero se cree
que un gran número de casos de violencia
doméstica y de las muertes que conlleva
no se reportan las víctimas de violencia
doméstica que escapan de la muerte
suelen quedar marcadas de por vida
eloise cuya verdadera identidad no puede
ser revelada huyó de su casa y el
maltrato de su ex marido
fácilmente podría haberse convertido en
otra trágica estadística
eloise fue atacado con un machete
afirma que la reacción de sus hijos le
salvó la vida el agarro el machete y me
pegó por todas partes cuando estaba a
punto de levantar el cuchillo para
cortarme la cabeza los niños se
levantaron uno lo agarró por las piernas
y el otro por los brazos dijeron papá no
la mates estamos cansados de ver sangre
desde este intento de asesinato en 2018
eloise ha vivido escondida y con miedo
porque su expareja la sigue buscando
las víctimas de violencia doméstica en
camerún no cuentan con ningún sistema
que las ayude o las proteja
me cambio de casa para escapar de él fue
a la escuela amenazar a los niños quería
averiguar dónde estábamos viviendo con
él
los niños no le dijeron nada estamos
divorciados pero no puedo vivir en paz
la paz es difícil de encontrar estas
mujeres sólo pueden contar consigo
mismas para tratar de encontrar algo de
seguridad y los recursos legales son
pocos o inexistentes no podemos permitir
que él siga haciendo estas cosas
desminar si es como si controlara sus
vidas en camerún no existe una ley
específica que trate la violencia
doméstica el problema simplemente se
aborda como una agresión muchas mujeres
no pueden y tampoco se atreven a
emprender la difícil lucha por la
justicia durante más de 30 años
charlotte chang con te ha apoyado y
guiado a las víctimas de violencia para
evitar que se conviertan en víctimas de
asesinato el lema de la abogada
camerunesa es intervenir antes de que
sea demasiado tarde
has pensado en hablar con las
autoridades sobre estas amenazas
no
porque el problema ya está
si la corte está tratando las heridas
causadas por el machete que impulsa a
julia leigh de la machete pero ahora él
está cometiendo otros delitos que debes
denunciar ante las autoridades y las
amenazas que él ha hecho son
injustificadas de esta abogada se reúne
con docenas de mujeres cada mes les
ofrece asesoría gratuita y las acompaña
en todos los procedimientos legales pero
en la mayoría de los casos no se dicta
una condena y el número de feminicidios
en camerún sigue aumentando
charlotte chan count e afirma que los
maridos y las parejas tienen permitido
actuar con impunidad judicial para ella
la culpa es del sistema patriarcal y
corrupto
hay un aumento de la violencia que lleva
a la muerte de las mujeres esto ocurre
una y otra vez y admito que es algo muy
preocupante
muchas de las personas que cometen estos
actos criminales están libres
si tienen libertad para ir a donde
quieran
y en el fondo se burlan de sus víctimas
en la ley
y de la lou a uno gracias al dinero que
tienen y que le pueden dar a cualquiera
según los defensores de derechos el gran
problema que enfrentan las mujeres es el
deficiente sistema jurídico y la
aceptación tradicional del maltrato
dentro de un matrimonio la onu considera
que más de la mitad de las mujeres en
camerún son víctimas de violencia
doméstica y sólo pocas de ellas podrán
ver que se haga justicia